le jour même de son anniversaire le jour
de ses 83 ans le général augusto
pinochet a pris connaissance de la
décision dé chambre des lords de la
chambre des lords anglais ceux ci ont
confirmé la légalité de l'arrestation
d'anciens dictateur chilien le 16
octobre dernier sur requête de la police
espagnole pour répondre de crimes commis
alors qu'il dirigeait la junte militaire
au chili
nous allons évoquer tous les aspects de
cette situation du général pinochet de
la décision anglaise voici pour
commencer les conditions dans lesquelles
les cinq magistrats de la chambre des
lords ont rendu leur avis c'était en
début d'après midi trois voix contre
deux le verdict de la chambre des lords
et sans appel
augusto pinochet sénateur à vie et
ancien dirigeant du chili s'est vu
refuser l'immunité diplomatique
un verdict surprise de la juridiction
suprême britannique qui ouvre la voie à
une extradition vers l'espagne de
l'ancien dictateur
un verdict accueilli par une explosion
de joie par les quelques 200
manifestants massés devant le parlement
chilien parents des victimes de la
répression citoyens d'amérique du sud ou
militants leur joie est totale
al'inverse madame thatcher ancien
ministre premier ministre conservateur a
estimé que vous stockez de chez ag est
affaibli devait rentrer dans son pays
le dossier est maintenant sur le bureau
de ministre de l'intérieur britannique
il a jusqu'au 2 décembre pour rendre sa
décision à santiago du chili le
président monsieur eduardo frei a
aussitôt déclaré que son gouvernement
contestait la décision de la chambre des
lords et qu'il s'efforcerait d'éviter
son extradition et dès ce soir le
ministre chilien des affaires étrangères
a pris l'avion pour londres dans la
capitale chilienne les partisans du
général pinochet et les anciens
adversaires de celui ci ont manifesté
leurs réactions respectives ce fut pour
les adversaires de pinochet des
manifestations de joie bruyante tandis
que des responsables des partis de
droite qualifiaient d' humiliation la
décision britannique à santiago du chili
pour france 2 reportages philippe gassot
cette journée aura été la plus longue
pour les familles des victimes qui se
bat depuis 25 ans l'information tombe
pinochet ne rentrera pas à la maison
c'est incroyable
chaque réponse entraîne son flot son
trop plein de sentiments contenu depuis
trop longtemps pour une fois ceux qui
n'ont jamais été entendus ceux qui n'ont
compté que pour du malheur on le droit
de relever la tête
inimaginable c'est le plus beau jour de
ma vie
il y à 23 ans que mon mari a disparu et
aujourd'hui c'est le jour où la justice
est arrivé dans mon pays pour que le
chili ne connaissent plus jamais ça ni
au chili ni ailleurs
et aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour pour
nous et pour tous nos disparus
elles ont toutes perdu un père un frère
ou un mari une manifestation improvisée
se forme pas de police pas de forces de
l'ordre juste une joie énorme partagé
par les passants et par les lycéens
enfin ceux qui ont tant pleuré se met à
espérer
dans le camp pinochet où l'on affichait
déjà la victoire
on crie maintenant à l'injustice au
complot la droite est bien décidé à ne
pas laisser faire on sait à gauche que
c'est un long travail qui commence
il va falloir plusieurs jours pour
croire à la victoire
car ici ça n'était pas gagné d'avancé et
le fils aîné de l'ancien dictateur s'est
exprimé à santiago du chili en fin
d'après-midi s'adressant à des partisans
de son père à augusto pinochet qui porte
donc le même prénom que son père s'était
rendu à londres dès l'arrestation de
celui il ya une chose que nous ne
pouvons pas oublier mon père a reçu ce
coup le jour de son anniversaire avec un
sadisme et le cruauté qui vont beaucoup
plus loin que les conditions réelles des
droits de l'homme aujourd'hui ne fait
aucun doute et d'une décision politique
partisane et sectaires qui a triomphé
nous allons maintenant à madrid de
retenir et qu'il ya eu aussi des
réactions notamment des ressortissants
originaires d'amérique du sud cette
après midi dans les rues de madrid
oui on peut dire qu'à madrid s'était
aussi l'explosion de joie les cris les
larmes d'une centaine de manifestants
avaient comme vous le disiez beaucoup de
chiliens d'argentins qui criait il est
tombé l'assassin et donc ils se sont
rassemblés sur la place de la puerta del
sol
c'est un rassemblement organisé par des
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme et plusieurs partis de gauche
donc on veut parler du noyau dur
antiputsch m mais les organisateurs
attendent beaucoup
ce soir est sans doute tard dans la nuit
place à majorque pour fêter cette
victoire contre l'impunité
alors il ya surtout un homme qui
symbolise tout ça c'est le juge garzon
je suppose
oui tout à fait c'est la grande victoire
du juge baltasar garzon que les
madrilènes appel superbe attaque parce
que c'est lui qui le premier a osé
poursuivre le général pinochet c'est
grâce à lui que le général a été arrêté
et aujourd'hui avec cette décision
disons dans les prochains jours il va
pouvoir inculpé formellement le général
pinochet pour crimes de génocide torture
est aussi terrorisme enfin le
gouvernement espagnol a fait savoir
qu'il respectait cette décision de
justice britannique
mais on sait que c'est une décision qui
doit embarrassé le chef du gouvernement
oc marie asnar étant donné l'importance
des relations commerciales avec le chili
merci dorothée la fille de l'ex
président socialiste chilien salvador
allende qui trouva la mort en septembre
1973 lors du coup d'état mené par le
général pinochet est arrivé cet après
midi à madrid voici un extrait de sa
réaction
olivia aujourd'hui c'est le triomphe des
principes et du droit international
la quatrième de ce que l'humanité et la
communauté internationale ont réclamé
cela signifie non à l'impunité et oui à
la justice
notre satisfaction est énorme parce que
malheureusement pendant 25 ans
l'impunité a régné dans notre pays
alors après les faits les différentes
réactions concernant le sort du général
pinochet
nous proposons maintenant un rappel
historique de la dictature chilienne
puis des derniers événements qui ont
conduit l'ancien dictateur à l'ombre
commentaires patrice fontaine
il y à bien plus d'un char d'un soldat
ou d'un avion en ce 11 septembre 1973
pour détruire le palais de la moneda
dans quelques minutes le locataire des
lieux salvatore allende va mourir le
général pinochet s'empare du pouvoir et
impose une dictature qui d'entrée se
donne les moyens de perdurer
pineau chez dissous le parlement suspend
les partis politique proscrit le
communisme se proclame chef suprême de
la nation
plus tard viendra l'état de siège et
malheur aux opposants ici on arrête là
on tire sur des civils sans vraiment se
cacher devenu président de la république
pinochet prendra pour habitude de
regrouper les suspects dans le stade de
santiago
dernière étape avant l'assassinât ou la
disparition combien de victimes à 3 4
milles suffisamment en tout cas pour que
des mères des pères des enfants
brandissent le portrait d'un proche et
interroge
où est il mais la dictature et forte
efficace a noyé la contestation
en fait que pinochet ne quittera le
pouvoir que parce qu'il aura bien voulu
il procède par étapes en 89
il n'est plus président de la république
mais il reste commandant en chef de
l'armée de terre
cela durera neuf ans avant que le 10
mars dernier ils finissent par se
contenter d'un titre de sénateur à vie
le voilà qui signe sa lettre de
transfert de pouvoirs au général isolées
et ça c'est donc en simple sénateur à
vie que le 16 octobre dernier pinochet
débarque à londres pour se faire opérer
d'une hernie discale
les à madrid un juge espagnol baltasar
garzon saisie de multiples plaintes
demande l'arrestation et l'extradition
de pinochet soupçonné de génocide
torture et terrorisme protestations du
gouvernement chilien protestations de
pinochet qui argue de son immunité
diplomatique
mais déjà des exilés chiliens se
manifeste en suisse en france en suède
au danemark en belgique en allemagne de
partout influent les demandes
d'extradition
dans un premier temps la haute cour de
justice de londres annuler le mandat
d'arrêt contre pinochet elle autorise
même sa libération sous caution
les espagnols font appel et c'est à la
chambre des lords la plus haute instance
judiciaire britannique qu'il revient de
se prononcer aujourd'hui 25 novembre
elles jugent non valides l'immunité
diplomatique dont se prévaut pinochet
conséquence elle ouvre la voie à
l'extradition vers l'espagne du
dictateur plusieurs familles françaises
de victimes de la dictature chilienne
avait porté plainte pour crimes contre
l'humanité ce soir l'un des avocats des
familles maître boulanger souhaite une
concertation européenne de tous les
défenseurs des victimes
une équipe de france 2 avec françois
privat et philippe ritaine était cet
après midi à niort en compagnie d'une
femme d'origine chilienne réfugié en
france depuis 23 ans
son mari a été assassiné en 1975 elle a
appris la décision avec beaucoup
d'émotion elle avait perdu tout espoir
yasmine ménanteau reste à tout jamais
une femme brisée par la perte de son
mari un berthod militants
d'extrême-gauche torturé et assassiné en
1975 par des miliciens aux ordres
d'agosto pinochet sur un guéridon la
photo d'un berthod mort à 24 ans ici une
présence permanente
mais depuis son assassinat en avril 75
yasmine s'était tu un jour je venais
juste le quitter et rentre chez sa mère
et il y à des hommes armés et en civil
qu'il attendait qu'ils ont mis dans une
camionnette et
ils sont partis nous avons fait avec sa
mère des recherches partout d'un
centième en nous sommes dit il faudrait
peut-être aller à la morgue avec
l'espoir qu'ils ne soient pas là et nous
avons constaté avec horreur avec sa mère
à quel point on l'avait torturés on lui
avait arraché un mois on lui avait
totalement détruit son corps le 23
octobre dernier
yasmine ménanteau s'est rendu à londres
avec des chiliens venus de toute
l'europe
elle a manifesté devant la clinique ou à
augusto pinochet des d'hospitaliser
imaginer que des prix que tous aient
tout cela s'est passé au chili
jamais nous n'avons pu parler nous avons
vécu toutes ces années dans le silence
la douleur profonde saint jamais parlé à
personne vivre vivre avec le silence et
la douleur et puis tout d'un coup il ya
un espoir l'espoir est immense
yasmine vient de déposer une plainte
contre l'ancien dictateur chilien pour
crimes contre l'humanité
avec l'espoir d'assister un jour à son
procès etienne l art à londres ce genre
de témoignage a pas être examiné par les
magistrats de la chambre des lords mais
alors connais ton quand même les
motivations de l'addition qu'ils ont
pris cet après midi
écouter claude la décision qui a été
rendue par les lords et résumées les
attendus sont résumés dans un document
qui fait pas moins de 62 pages mais si
c'est une décision qui est historique et
bien c'est parce que pour la première
fois un ancien chef d'état pourra être
jugés dans un autre pays que le sien
pour des crimes comme génocide les
crimes de torture alors vous savez qu'on
s'attendait à ce que les l'ordre de
cette cour suprême qui sont plutôt en
général considérés comme des
conservateurs s'en tiennent au strict
droit anglais qui considère que les
anciens chefs d'état sont couvert par
une immunité diplomatique et bien trois
lord sur cinq ont donc préféré se
référer à des conventions
internationales comme la convention de
genève qui date de 1961 où la charte de
nuremberg qui datent même de 1945 et
donc ont permis d'engager cette
procédure d'extradition qui va
maintenant commencer alors la procédure
à venir que qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant
écoutez la première étape ce sera dès la
semaine prochaine le général pinochet
pourrait être obligé de comparaître
physiquement devant la cour de wall
street qui se veut une cour qui s'occupe
de spécialement des problèmes
d'extradition mais vous savez que la
procédure va devenir beaucoup plus
politique puisque c'est au ministre de
l'intérieur britannique qu'il reviendra
de dire si le général pinochet peut être
extradé ou non vers l'espagne et à tous
les stades de la procédure
eh bien les avocats du général ont de
multiples recours possibles on s'attend
à une longue longue bataille juridique
qui est aussi en train de devenir une
bataille politique dès cet après midi
madame thatcher qui est une amie du
général pinochet de longue date a
demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
d'autoriser son retour dans son pays
pour des raisons humanitaires parce
qu'il serait fatigué et malade et l'on
attend toujours la réaction de tony
blair qui doit être l'un des rares
premiers ministres européens ne toujours
pas avoir réagi à l'heure qu'il est
merci etienne nous allons maintenant à
santiago du chili philippe gassot les
réactions on a vu dans la rue notamment
d'un certain nombre de jeunes gens deux
jeunes femmes qui pour les uns et les
autres d'ailleurs n'était pas forcément
né en 1973
mais quelle est l'ambiance générale que
vous avez pu découvrir ce soir à
santiago du chili et bien côté on a vécu
je peux dire une journée historique avec
des gens vous l'avez vu qu'ils se sont
embrassés qui pleurait qui se
retrouvaient et au milieu de tout ça il
y avait toujours la question qu'allons
nous faire
non alors du côté de la gauche on sait
que la route qui mène à la justice ici
au chili sera longue et semée d'embûches
et du côté du général pinochet du côté
de la droite dure
eh bien on a vu ce matin qu'on voulait
donner le ton on a parlé de déni de
justice et il ya même une équipe de la
bbc qui a été molesté par les supporters
du général pinochet
vous voyez que la route qui mène à la
réconciliation sera longue
également si philippe en france 7 au
cours des questions d'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale que le député
communiste maxime gremetz a annoncé à
ses collègues la décision des lords
applaudissements quasi générale des
députés français en revanche le front
national estime qu'il s'agit là d'un
crime d'état hispano britannique
le président chirac a ainsi commenté la
nouvelle il n'est pas acceptable que les
crimes puissent rester impuni toute la
lumière doit être faite sur les
responsabilités n'a augusto pinochet a
dit le président de la république et
puis le premier ministre lionel jospin
dans les couloirs de l'assemblée a parlé
d'une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
dictateurs c'est une surprise c'est une
joie
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
dictateurs
je ne sais pas comment maintenant la
procédure judiciaire va se poursuivre
avec la france a transmis et même une
demande en tout état de cause dont j'ai
l'impression ce soir c'est que le chemin
vers la justice internationale l'idée
qu'aucun crime ne pourra rester impuni
vient à nouveau de progresser par une
voix un peu inattendu mais ô combien
symbolique